- pleasure - because goldmine drowning
with you right now but role model you
must feel like this this the sense of
you know a second chance at team I feel
like the Desmond choo choooo show
business I got all the bloated kid from
Cambodian Cryer this is too cool
remember that I got denim acuity but not
a child in his arms yeah I feel great I
feel really fortunate to be here and to
be able to stand and do the things that
I'd love to do is stand up again and not
only just decide to be my play my
daughter and my wife and be my family
and be able and yeah yeah
I have my faculties there and still
fortunate you know a lot of people would
have given up after something all I said
that Elliott but people didn't really
realize what I was saying yeah most
people have to suffer in it injuries
like that would it give up right right
so what my right there cheer anymore
order in therapy and physical therapy
and made me work harder
can you can you elaborate on that
relationship through this no my lady
yeah she's my gravity's my stone why do
you think I put so hard in that coma
he'll come back god bless him could be
well huh and my daughter my god a fourth
man he did I fought I'm amidst this mrs.
Obama missus I love life I don't know
nothing about no death I'm a little
something about it when I wasn't down
remember it I just love doing this going
stand up for Netflix that's where they
came to me with this opportunity at what
Netflix from the first one to say won't
you do stand-up he's gonna rank didn't
know if I was all dead right they gave
me an opportunity to walk on stage and
do my thing right right right so that's
what I did
that must have pumped you up let daily a
lot is somebody for that fix to believe
in me so I feel about it and how do you
feel to be part of this Netflix family
now you see the company I'm in good
company
I'm in some pretty damn good company and
I don't mind
I just want to over hold up my part of
the bargain for sure and you have man we
watched your special it is it is amazing
and I ask the question why now for a
comedy special like this why not plan
yeah why not you tackle the the accident
head-on right from the start and it goes
without the way yeah there are things
going on my life as you see other things
happen to me just besides getting about
trust in fishing I got married I was all
about it my daughter started walking
I'll never do caitlyn jenner's around
talk about it to bother you for you I
came out the gold was perfect material
Thanks right yeah is that like stars
aligned for you when you come out of
that coma like look at all this material
yes I waited all this is waiting for
Tracy Morgan is that it didn't happen
overnight though yeah it didn't happen
overnight I have people to support me
and then with me yeah got my career and
I got my family and my wife stepped up
when I was on my back it's a good girl
you've made us laugh so hard with this
special I think you know you've always
made us laugh so it's really big for
Netflix yeah hope is really good for
them and good for people more the
Netflix always really good for the world
I hope I could be a part of making them
laugh and laugh again bottom line that's
that's what you want to do in life
obviously next year don't want to make
people laughing that's all I want to do
him I don't mean it alone just won't be
funny and you want to chase at the end
of the day and at the beginning of the
day before we think man Thank You Tomas